[ __ ] who revealed that she and husband
Carey Hart are in marriage counseling
Carey and I have been in couples
counseling almost our entire 17 years
that we've been together why is that
been a only reason we're still together
because he speaks polish I speak Italian
and she speaks both like we don't speak
the same language we come from broken
families and we had no model of how are
we supposed to keep this family together
and live this crazy life pink revealed
on today the difficulties that she has
caused in the marriage
I am a hard person to be in a
relationship with I'm I have a really
high bar for myself and a really high
bar for others and that makes it very
difficult to love me pink who just
released her eighth album hurts to be
human
what's incredibly honest with Michelle
about rough spots in her relationship
and finding their happy place you said
it well you don't hand your your wedding
ring back I haven't some time to really
longer I used to throw it I think I
threw it in the pool once I was think I
was standing on top of a grotto saying
to all of his friends I never see you
again
have a nice I mean but then you guys
have made this incredible family and you
probably look back and you're like how
we did this yeah yeah yeah I believe in
the work I believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]